like the life a lot of us had to go
through was like damn near like the
Olympics you know and the training you
got to go through that so like it's only
fitting me get these gold medals at the
end you know hey what's up G Q this is
belly on the rocks I get the best stone
so definitely bust on this is like them
yeah I love rocking one rose I think
it's the classy way to do things
you know I mean you know I got to go
overboard I wanted like 1/10 of Slick
Rick collection like Slick Rick had the
Tori
another kid puff - there's puffed up
people with diamonds are about I can
have this little thing on about 20 a
year change like puff coffee boy real
diamonds look like of course like the
Cuban link with the matching bracelet
bust down a forest it's rare I wear
these anymore
when we first jumped on it it was like a
few people it's almost like a uniform
now you know I don't really like to wear
this all moves around you know there's
only a few pieces that I feel like I'm
married to for life like the
yacht-master example like I can't see
myself ever getting rid of this watch or
nothing you know I mean everything else
is gonna have a style in a day that it's
cool and the day that it's not you know
but like a classic Rolex that's never
going out of style I guess growing up
and looking at guys like big and stuff
like that like I always wanted to Rolex
I mean I learned young is watching the
shoes got in the old point come on AP
bus down too many I think I'm like
phasing out of the diamond I where'd the
yacht-master a lot more than I wear this
is the sky the weather row ducks and
when you look at a Rolexes I stopped by
Rolex and opposed to the Rolex
not you know it's a big difference you
know I mean I'd rather just go for those
and if I can't get those I just want a
plain
this was actually a birthday gift for my
brother cash this for my brother mani
most of the best jewelry that I got is
from the homies like just gifts that I
get from people I'd do the same thing in
return
I gave able a map of Ethiopia it was all
iced out with a red ruby on the spot
that he's from you know most of the best
gifts that different people are Chinese
this of course EXO dog tag that's my
brother Sal Gaming is a gift from him to
me sounds like my big bro man even if I
get myself a piece and you know likely
to show up with a better piece make that
all for this style designed it himself
and made it for me so it's a pretty
unique piece in there since it's more
for the EXO that's on it than for the
flashiness of it it would mean I strike
a Tourette minute I'm always reppin my
team my squad mister bleeding heart man
this is like this the logo of my company
it's like the emotions beating off the
[ __ ] it's got a couple teeth missing
right now but you know definitely fix
that I just put out a new single with
the weekend and I said I'm seeing a
sauce dripping off from the Heartless on
my sleeve that's the heart that's on my
sling right there you know man that's a
hard question
oh hold on my brother cash got the
skulls to legend I may be one of the
most ignorant pieces I ever seen in my
life
it's from my homeland are and then you
okay I just said meters it's a snake
like really like why I like to wear i
would like to wear it on my right hand
because most people just snaked me where
my right hand came a little important
that's like that's the analogy for that
so I really be rocking it right here
green emeralds rubies black diamonds
going on this proud of my newest piece
so so far hell yeah a lot of compliments
on this is this obsidian this was
actually a gift to me when I moved into
my new home this was a gift for my
brother Nick the piff and his wife man
you notice to keep the bad energy away
it's been working too I've been
happiness [ __ ] I'd like to have a pinky
on most of the time but again like more
classic man more chill vibes you know
what I mean like the big rigs for me are
going out of style that's not what I'm
into my first piece of jewelry was
ugly-ass ray I thought it was like the
illest ring ever until I grew up then I
look back at outside so ugly ass good
[Music]
yeah I had my tops to man when I left
him in Los Angeles I said y'all a
picture so I'm thinking a popular
position these actually match the like
the zipper vibes that I have this is
like the bottom to those this black
diamonds the white then
that is everything to me I mean a lot of
people notice me for my style as much as
they do for my music they'll be on my
page and like what's this I was dead a
lot of my [ __ ] even that I wear his
custom like I literally grow up pick the
fabrics and I don't even put a label on
I just don't want to be wearing a lot of
other people [ __ ] I feel like my trip is
nicer so you know you got the right
jewelry on you could be wearing all
black with just the jewelry on that you
still look like I'm tripping keep on
tripping that's it man find your drip
and drip my brother
[Music]